what's up guys my name is Hans and this
is my automobile that I live in the 2014
sprint was a sprinter van Freightliner
this is my shoes my shoes in here I
covered it up because it looks super
like I live in it if I have a bunch of a
shoe rack in my front some this is my
longboard station this is some free food
that I got from autumn Rogers and this
is the curtain it's magnetic you gotta
like to open it up and then you come in
here it's just a wonderland
all right there that's the it's the
switch it works like how your home
switches will probably work this is the
racks is a sink got a little foot pump
you just push on it no water comes out
yeah do the dishes
got a butane stove in here right there
and then I got this is the water
it's almost out I gotta fill it up again
and this is the if I can hold everything
in place
my [ __ ] that I made homemade this is a
fake thing I screwed it in this is real
this is fake
is it hooks I don't have a use for this
is my pee bottle on my garbage another
thing that I just made it duct taped it
this is all magnetized this isn't just a
window out so it's really a miserable so
let's close close that keep it positive
this is my fridge that I've never used
it's just storage for random food by the
way got cough drops this is my Ottoman
love this thing I use it all the time
that's my laundry this is my heater this
is like storage and this is just more
storage stuff this keeps everything in
place it's my command I can charge my
phone on here this turns on the fan this
turns on the inverter this turns on the
heater this turns on the lights and this
turns the whole thing off so it's not
glowing green when I sleep this is just
my forever like that that keeps it from
rocking around this is my fan I keep a
little cover on it
I should take that off to save time
and stuff that I'm doing a closet rod
way I can put it back at night velcroed
it's hailing outside this is my family's
for the summer and spits down late and
that's on the story just like a talk cuz
I'm artistic artistic and that's pretty
much it forget what else I have in here
that's all I need to survive and that's
all you need to survive you're such a
[ __ ]